that's one of the things I I think that
is if there's a silver lining at all
that that's even to be said to come out
of this is that people are realizing you
have to take your security in your own
hands and your your own first responder
I can't tell you how many people I've
talked to also who have reached out and
said ok I'm gonna go get I'm gonna get
my first gun I need to know what to get
where to go and what kind of training to
get which is awesome to see and I think
what is it it's like an 80% increase
from this time last year in terms of the
number of people who have purchased guns
and a huge significant portion of that
is women because people are watching
what they're seeing on television and
they're watching you know you can see
peaceful protests during the day but
then the Sun sets and you have all the
skinny fat kids in there all their black
hot topic here that come out to burn
down buildings because that is protected
speech but disagreement is violence and
people see this joining me today is a
radio host television personality Second
Amendment advocate and author of grace
canceled Dana Loesch welcome to the
Rubin report I'd agree with you Dana
thanks for having me my pleasure
all right so just to clear it up because
it's gonna be weird in about ten minutes
we taped an hour-long interview about
three weeks ago in the midst of the
corona craziness and we were stocking
some interviews just because generally
things have been a little nutty and you
never know when you can get people but
before we release that I wanted to do a
quick 10-minute follow-up with you that
we're gonna post at the top of that
interview and separately as a clip just
to kind of get us up to speed on
everything that's happening with George
Floyd with the protests the riots racism
gun rights the whole thing so how's that
for an open-ended intro where do you
want to start with all of this oh my
gosh we're I mean we're - yeah where to
start every it just feels like the
world's on fire kind of it does and and
even though it feels like there's
there's a lot of discussion and a lot of
people who are not listening everybody
wants to be heard and that's fine but I
also feel like there's no nuance and we
can't have any I feel like people are
too afraid to have honest
discussion honest I mean really I do I
feel like people are too afraid to have
an honest discussion because they don't
want to be cherry picked apart nuance is
dead and people are going to take the
absolute worst thing possible and they
are going to apply that and and
misinterpret anything that anyone says
so they can score a point and so real
genuine honest conversation cannot be
had we can't we can't even agree on what
the truth is anymore so I I mean I am
where do we go from here well listen if
only two people that were perhaps
talking right now had just released
books that in many ways deal with all of
these issues wouldn't that maybe have
perhaps possibly helped I think you are
onto something Dave I think you're onto
something that's a really good that's a
really good observation you're right
okay so let's let's start this way then
what I've seen is that it seems to me
that everybody across the political
spectrum almost with no exclusions is
completely disgusted by what happened to
George Floyd they want justice to be
served they want there to be a proper
investigation all of that and that there
could have been a moment where we could
have come together here and instead I
would say bad actors mostly an tyfa sort
of combined with black lives matter have
taken advantage and now we basically are
seeing our country and actually all over
the world cities that are on fire so to
sort of turn this to your specialty I'm
noticing that even here in the people's
banana republic of California in Los
Angeles that average people who never
would have thought about having a gun
are suddenly talking about getting
getting guns I have a couple friends
that just got guns this weekend you
can't get it immediately there's still
the 10-day waiting period but that went
to get guns this past weekend are you at
least enthused that people are gonna
take some of their security into their
own hands I am especially now that we're
being told that the police could be
defunded or demilitarized or however
they're trying to walk that back I mean
I that's one of the things I I think
that is if there's a silver lining at
all that that's even to be said to come
out of this is that people are realizing
you have to take your security and your
hands and your your own First Responder
I can't tell you how many people I've
talked to also who have reached out and
said okay I'm gonna go get I'm gonna get
my first gun I need to know what to get
and where to go and what kind of
training to get which is awesome to see
and I think what is it it's like an 80%
increase from this time last year in
terms of the number of people who have
purchased guns and a huge significant
portion of that is women because people
are watching what they're seeing on
television and they're watching you know
you can see peaceful protests during the
day but then the Sun sets and you have
all the skinny fat kids and they're all
they're black hot topic here that come
out to burn down buildings because that
is protected speech but disagreement is
violence and people see this I mean I've
been talking to business owners business
owners who who have have sacrificed so
much and they've been shut down for I
don't know how many like three months
now they barely made it through the
pandemic lockdown and now they have to
shut down again if there's going to be
riots in their area and they don't want
to have everything that they that they
work for destroyed and they're like okay
what do I do I need to be able to get a
fire I need to get a gun I need to get a
wonder I get a shotgun what do I've had
so many people ask me this and I'm glad
to see it I wish it wasn't under these
circumstances you know I wish that
people even during times of total safety
and security would realize that you know
this is this is a right that everyone
should be able to exercise no matter
where they are or what side of the
political aisle they fall on what do you
make of a meme that we're sort of seeing
out of the left these days that you sort
of reference there which is that words
are violence but apparently now violence
is in violence so we're hearing this all
over the place now that violence against
property is not violence I'm pretty sure
that if someone burned down your house
you might consider it a violent act am I
crazy dana loesch no you're not at all
I'm pretty sure if one of the people
saying that had their house the fact
that are their business affected and
burned down they probably changed their
mind on that real quick that is violence
that's a weird thing about it if you
have disagreed with an Tifa or the
far-left on anything disagreement itself
is so provocative that it's tantamount
to violence alone but if you engage in
the actual physical activity of violence
and whether you're assaulting people are
setting fire to something that's somehow
protected speech and by justifying
disagreeing speech and
presenting it as violence they're
finding they're just now fabricating
ways to justify their actual physical
violence they've they want to argue
themselves their way out of it and I
that's so dangerous I don't like speech
being portrayed as violence it's not
physical violence as violence speech
itself is is not violent it's not
anything but speech so I know we talked
about the the silver lining part of this
that people are thinking about their own
personal security and their family's
security and and that's good as a
conservative are you kind of surprised
that the wake up call to this was sort
of amorphous mobs coming to people's
property and businesses as opposed to
overreaching government right because
usually conservatives frame the oh I've
got to have a gun to keep government
away from my property but this is to
keep citizens we we thought we had
police that could do that now we've got
police kneeling in the streets yeah no I
think that's a good question I think
some of it too is I do think that some
political parties bears some
responsibility with us so in some regard
it is a little bit government but yeah
that isn't that kind of what the Second
Amendment has always been for it's that
uncomfortable aspect of it that everyone
whispers about while they all say that
it's really just it's only about hunting
and self-defense yes but also it's to
keep your government in check and that's
why we're so different from every other
country out there and with this you know
Antipa seems with all the expose is
going on about a antifa
I mean they're they're now classified as
a terror group they're sort of they act
kind of like this militant far left arm
of the Democrat Party I don't I can't
see any candidates being prevailed upon
to denounce their violence they soap for
soap it seems like they just kinda
pretend that they don't exist in fact I
think some of them had said oh no this
is just these are just like little local
groups it's not really an organized
national effort but it but it is yeah
but it is well you saw you saw Keith
Ellison's picture with the anti-fur book
from yeah a year ago right let's not
yeah since deleted it but this guy was
almost in charge of the DNC he lost by a
couple votes and he's the Attorney
General of what state and he said yeah
of Minnesota yeah and he's and he
supports and he supports an Tifa look
about what I guess it was about two
years ago I cut a short just commentary
about Antipa violence and this was at
the height whenever
was writing on college campuses and how
dare they bring in a conservative to
talk to anybody and they were setting
trash cans on fire and busting up
windows and I played footage of this
video and I was condemning the violence
and the far-left who engaged in it and
defended it turned around and said that
I was calling for violence by condemning
their violence because condemning their
violence by itself is a provocative act
and we're in an upside-down world right
now where we're wrong is right right is
wrong everything is awful cats and dogs
living together it's like that line that
Bill Murray has run out right now all
right so I got one more for you and then
we'll play the full hour interview for
the people that are like my my friends
that I talked about this weekend who are
getting guns for the first time what
what would you want them to know what
resources would you send them to for the
people that have just their whole lives
have been anti-gun or never thought ever
ever ever that they would have a gun in
the home that are now rethinking it
what's sort of the most what's the best
piece of advice you can give them as
they enter into this world they need to
get something that they feel comfortable
shooting first off and it also depends
on whether or not this is something that
they're gonna use for home defense or if
they're going to go get their concealed
carry license and if it's gonna be
something that they carry I have a lot
of different firearms for different
purposes whether it's you know my
bedside I hear something you know my
alarm goes off in the middle of the
night or if I'm wearing a cocktail dress
and I am going to an evening event you
know there's something else that you
know it's like shoes you know you got to
have you gotta have some variety but I
you know I always say you can't really
ever go wrong with a shotgun
you really can't if you don't have a
rifle if you've never you've never shot
a semi-automatic if you don't have a
handgun shotguns are always that's
always like a really good first choice
and the cool thing about gun owners is
that they are so incredibly helpful good
law-abiding gun owners all across the
country are so eager to share with you
what they have found works for them and
what doesn't what kind of training works
really well there's all kinds of like
you know you have the California rifle
and pistol Association out where you are
some really awesome people that do
really good training they're like
up-to-date with everything and they have
really
recommendations as well as to where you
can go what ranges you can go to I mean
we people even get it down to you know
ammo selections for crying out loud so
there's there's so many resources out
but I always tell people if you're not
you know if you if you've never been
around firearms
shotguns always something really good to
start with for handguns I like to
recommend like a Glock 19 which is
personal preference of mine you know six
our p3 65mph out there and a lot of
these a lot of the manufacturers out
there - these all started you know that
a lot of them are American companies
American manufactured American jobs and
that's one of the other focuses I think
of our issues today is keeping
everything right here in the US of A all
right Dana thanks for doing this pick up
and now I present everyone else with my
interview with Dana Loesch hey I'm Dave
Rubin and this is the Reuben report
quick reminder everybody to subscribe to
our YouTube channel and click that
little Bell over there so that you're
notified when our videos come out and
joining me today is a wife a mom a radio
host and author of the new book grace
cancelled Dana Loesch finally welcome to
the Reuben report thank you for having
me I appreciate it's good to be with you
again this is like what twice and now
one month this is the most we've ever
spoken I we had gone years not speaking
or at least you know not in full
sentences just through Twitter and then
I was on your show a couple days ago and
we had booked you we booked you just as
lockout began you were gonna come to LA
and then locket I dropped right at the
start of a lockdown which is perfect
timing
publishers love that they love so you
and I both did the same thing we both
released books in the middle of a
lockout how's it going for you did they
try to stop you my guys really wanted us
to push but I was like no we're getting
this freaking thing out I can't sit on
it anymore what was that process like
for you it was well it was a little
daunting the first I had the first week
press tour which is always the craziest
when a book is out that first week and I
was in New York for most of it this was
right at the end of February and then I
went to DC when they were having CPAC
and I had
an event there and then I was to go to
Northern California and then I was to
see you in LA and then do a couple of
other things in SoCal and then I had to
go to Minneapolis and there were 22
dates that I had across the country and
one by one they all started getting
cancelled and the first one was in San
Francisco and then Sacramento followed
and then my publisher was like I don't
think that you you might have like
difficulty in getting home even if you
fly out there at this point so maybe we
should start canceling some stuff so
yeah it was just that first week yeah
and here we are alright so we're gonna
do this on the Skype or whatever pipes
or wires we're using I'm not even sure
at the moment but we'll go ahead and do
it anyway so from I know that most of my
audience obviously knows who you are but
I think for the people that maybe don't
or maybe know your name but don't know
exactly what you do I think they sort of
think oh dana loesch like that's the gun
lady like something like that how would
you really you know I mentioned mom and
wife and I took that stuff from your
from your Twitter bio but what do you
really sort of consider yourself first
at at a professional level
I think professionally I mean just radio
host and author and TV commentator and I
I have been in politics for for quite a
long time actually get started in
college doing opposition research for
Democrats and so that's how that's how
professionally politically it started
and I cover so many issues but obviously
the Second Amendment I think is the one
that I'm that I'm most known for just
because it's such a personal issue and
it's something about which I'm so
passionate and I know a lot about it and
I've shoot a lot and I have a lot of
guns and so it just you know kind of
goes hand in hand but I think most
people sort of see me and sort of see me
in that vein and maybe like the devil
incarnate it just all depends I think on
well speaking of the devil incarnate I
am gonna read some of the blurbs on the
back of your book because you did
something actually pretty cool it pretty
hilarious with the back libs but we'll
hold that we'll hold that for just a
second so before we dive into guns and
we'll talk about all the hot topic stuff
and and all that what's going on with
you and and lockdown how's life in what
it what are you feeling about how the
states are going about doing things as
we're recording this right now we are
holding it for a little bit but I just
found out that it sounds like my state
of California or at least my adopted
state of California is now gonna be
closed for another three months
even though virtually nobody is sick and
everyone's going bananas how's it been
for you what are you hearing from your
audience and the rest of it
for me it hasn't changed a lot because
I'm kind of like you I work from home
but I have gotten busier as weird as it
is because now my kids are home my
oldest sons in college and he's home
which is actually pretty awesome because
he wants to go into constitutional law
and so he has a lot of very politically
charged classes and I just look at it as
an excellent opportunity to set straight
anything that he is unlearned while he
has been in college and actually show
him like this is this is how you you
approached balanced research and and
this is where you you go and you get a
multitude of different viewpoints and
iron sharpens iron it's been a little
it's been a little hectic because the
kids are home but otherwise i I'm kind
of a situational extrovert anyway so on
that end it hasn't really affected me
and I am really blessed in that regard
but what has affected me is hearing so
many stories of people and friends of
mine who own businesses and they're
terrified as to what's gonna happen and
the town in which I live we've lost a
number of businesses already I was
talking to another friend of mine who
owns a salon and she's terrified about
what's going to happen they can't they
can't get the those paycheck protection
loans because some of the banks won't
call them back they go with Chase Bank
they're not hearing back from Chase Bank
and that's that's not like the exception
that seems to be sort of the general
rule with these situations it's really
hard for some of these businesses to
hear back from some of these banks and
to just I mean you when you consider
that these people have had their ability
to engage in commerce seized it's like a
it's it really is a quasi eminent domain
I there's no other better way I can
describe it and their ability to
generate income and to engage in
commerce has been seized and they're
told well we'll provide for you for your
needs temporarily but then they're not
able to even access that it's really
rough and I don't think that people you
know you're talking about
LA County may be going under an
additional three months of lockdown I
don't think that that's gonna happen
people can't they can't survive like
that people cannot survive what do you
make of our public officials what I
would basically say is like an inability
talk to us in a mature way like even
when I just heard this three-month thing
which it sounds like it's still we're
not totally sure but like they're
floating out this idea it's like they
don't tell us why they're doing things
they don't say oh these things these
policies have worked here
these policies haven't worked here they
don't say oh we haven't found any cases
that are killing people in people under
40 that are otherwise healthy but we
know it's affecting people over 80 like
that there's just no sense making coming
out of almost anyone at a political
level and I don't mean everybody I think
Greg Abbott in Texas is doing a pretty
nice job
you know there are a couple people doing
it but that's so many of our political
leaders think that just because they say
something that that sort of is divine
right just then it yeah and and a lot of
those orders that you mentioned they're
I mean they're not law per se as one
thinks of law I mean these nye they
don't have the force or effect of law
tradition only something passed by state
legislatures or something passed by
Congress and I Newsom is weird your
governor is weird because he started out
kind of doing okay and then he lost his
senses and then he decided to punish
Orange County and you're right there is
a little bit of nannying going on there
in terms of the way that they speak to
you about things I feel like we're not
kids we fund you you know we pay your
salaries we are responsible enough to
understand why it is you're telling us
these things similar to in the very
beginning when they were telling folks
you don't need to wear masks don't worry
about wearing masks don't go definitely
don't go and get those in 95s or any
surgical masks you guys don't need those
it's not gonna stop it well turns out
they were just terrified that everybody
was gonna rush to buy those masks and
after that nobody wanted to believe what
any of these leaders were telling us
anymore because if they're gonna lie
about something like that what else
would they what else would they
misconstrue and not only that but if you
were to put a video out right now if we
told people not to wear masks our videos
would be taken down on YouTube even
though the w-h-o is saying that very
same thing you know just just a couple
weeks ago so for people so I know we're
like minded on the Liberty side of
things and we believe in the
Constitution I mean real real political
radicals here but for the Liberty minded
people that do want to figure
a way to put food on their family's
table that want to figure out a way to
go to work again or literally even I was
just I was saying a David last night I
was like I would like to invite friends
over for dinner friends that I know have
been in quarantine their health the RA
is like not criminal activity but like
we just have friends over for dinner but
what what do you think the liberty
minded people like what are the best
tactics that we should be doing as we
try to push on the government as opposed
to just like running around and and just
masks off and and the whole thing like
do you do you see a way we can do this
sensibly he's not gonna do it for us or
something like that yeah no I think
that's a good question I I love the
story Shelly Luthor the salon that's
maybe a 45 minutes for me she really
they had reduced the salons capacity she
was following all of the guidelines that
all the medical professionals were
putting out she wasn't doing it as a
stunt but she legitimately was another
one of those business owners where she
couldn't go and get any kind of loan any
kind of help she has three kids single
mom she had you know our rent to pay for
her business I mean she really needed to
generate income the best way she could I
loved the civil disobedience aspect of
it here's one of the things that really
bugs me about the the mantra from the
house arrest people I can't even bring
myself to call it lockdown anymore they
think that it is that the law mandating
everyone or what they profess to be law
mandating that everybody stay home is
just because it is a law or they
perceive it to be a land that it's it's
not because it's right or because it's
just or ethical or moral it derives all
of its power from the fact that it is
the law which seems really ridiculously
cyclical and and I that doesn't I don't
really think that they have a good
understanding of that and I so I like
the civil disobedience aspect of it I
was telling a friend of mine I am
totally into the speakeasy culture now
I'm all about let's do it speakeasy
style and I was telling I was even
telling a friend of mine who works with
the governor here in Texas I'm like I'm
gonna just do speakeasy oh and come at
me come and make me instead of I'm gonna
take it come and make me and just have
like speakeasy salon I haven't had a
hair trim in like ten you know ten weeks
I know it's firstworldproblems but you
don't
to kind of get back to normal a little
bit and also give people a way to to
earn some money but the state has been
they've actually been kind of clever in
that they were threatening a lot of the
hairdresser's and cosmetologist with the
removal of their licenses so they do
have to be careful because you always
have that I call it that one turn the
punchbowl that always ruins everything
they always want to go tell on the
government someone is cutting hair
against the lockdown regulations we're
gonna go tell the police we're gonna go
tell you know the the licensing office
and we're gonna have their license
pulled it's ridiculous and so I I like
the civil disobedience but I have to
jokingly say that the more that the
state pushes against the people I'm not
saying that's how you get a Boogaloo but
I'm saying that might be how you get one
if you keep up those measures yeah well
speaking of shorter hair I'm not saying
that my hair is shorter than it was say
three days ago but it ain't me maybe it
is I'm just saying I'm not really saying
anything but maybe maybe it is maybe it
isn't what do you think what do you
think this says about generally like you
know for the for those of us that are
worried about authoritarianism for those
of us that are worried about governments
run amok how so many people sort of do
take what you just said there that they
hear a law and then that in and of
itself means it must be just or right or
something and then they just sort of
acquiesce do you think that is almost
like a symptom of the success of the
West that we don't even know now when
when tyranny is encroaching on our lives
like okay six months we're gonna sit in
our house for six months forty million
people will be unemployed the economy
will be tanking and and we're gonna all
go wait did anyone get sick did anyone
get sick yeah no I think that's a think
that's a great point and I think some of
it is there are a lot of people in this
country in our generation who've never
they've know that they've never
experienced a dictatorship they haven't
experienced any kind of tyranny they
it's a lot of us you know obviously we
lived through 9/11 and but we we've been
really far removed thankfully from a lot
of really bad stuff that previous
generations have endured and so we don't
really have anything to compare it to
and I think for some they think oh well
it's just temporary and isn't that kind
of how it always starts oh it's just
temporary just a little bit of our
Liberty for safety which is a horrible
trade-off they and you never get a
return on your investment and and with
this they think well these are good
people these are people we elected that
are that are telling us we need to stay
home and we need to listen to them and
again it goes back to just because it's
an executive order or it's a regulation
or it's a law that doesn't mean it's
just it doesn't mean it's right and
there are a lot of conservatives I have
to say that are kind of going along with
this too which really surprises me
because these these are people who would
complain against red flag laws but yeah
and and other forms of authoritarianism
but with something like this I mean they
don't even question what the trade-off
is I mean for instance what what is
flattening the curve didn't we already
flatten it so now we've gone from
flattening the curve to we have to stay
indoors until there's a vaccine
well no vaccine is ever a hundred
percent foolproof so what is the
ultimate point here yeah there's so much
here that's actually an interesting
segue to your book because obviously you
talked a lot about outrage culture it's
one of the things that I talk about a
lot too and I think partly what it is
with say the conservatives that
seemingly are giving over a lot of their
individual rights the government right
now I think what it is is that they're
honestly afraid of the outrage machine
they're afraid to push a little bit on
the Liberty side of things or on the
open up side because they don't want
that mob to come for them they don't
want to be seen as oh these you know the
way the media frames it that it's these
fringe racists right that was what CNN
was saying about you know the the
protesters in Michigan as if people were
protesting for racism they've wanted
jobs basically they wanted to live but I
think that's what it's like you get sort
of these average conservatives who I
would agree on on a lot of things but
then they're just like ah I don't want
to I don't want to push it because I
don't want the thing to come for me and
that's rarely how it works right or that
that that policy doesn't work for too
long
no and liberty is not something that's
supposed to be comfortable and and
that's the other thing I mean it's not a
guarantee of comfort and it's not a
guarantee of happiness that doesn't mean
that you're you're gonna live a life
completely without any challenge or any
adversity that's not what freedom is I
mean freedom is the ability to
enjoy the fruits of your labor and also
the consequences of your decision and
and and engage in free association look
people were totally happy to when we
were initially told but two weeks we
would just like for you all to kind of
lock down a little bit and help us
flatten the curve so we don't overwhelm
the medical resources and have like
another Italy on our hands everybody was
more than happy to do that and we it
wasn't because we were listening to the
government ordering us around it's
because we generally care about the
lives and safety and well-being of other
people regardless of what political
identity they have and you I mean if
you're gonna call yourself at a limited
government person I think part of that
goes with understanding that voluntary
stewardship good stewardship goes
hand-in-hand with that and people didn't
go out and protest until you had some of
these tiny tyrants I think as they've
been nicknamed across the country really
exerting authority that they didn't have
and they shouldn't have exerted and
really getting into the weeds with it
like banning seeds and saying you could
take a kayak out on a lake but you can't
take a boat with a motor because
apparently gas and motors make the rona
grow I don't know and and instituting
like curfews and all of this stuff and
that's when people begin to rightfully
question okay wait a minute we've been
doing all of this what is the point and
then the two weeks went from two weeks
to a month and then two months people
just want to be told the truth and they
and they want to feel as the other
elected officials are being forthright
with them and all of this showcased
something else entirely so that's when
people started protesting and and to
point out to in Michigan you always have
and as I understood it there were a
small group of people who came out and
decided to be you know butt heads about
it but that is not in any way indicative
of all of the protests that have been
happening across the country even in
California and for the media and and
others to focus on that one incident as
a way to invalidate the other protest is
a really disingenuous way of evaluating
the concerns of real people and it just
forces that chasm between the sides
apart further just to be clear so the
incident you referred to are you talking
about all the guys that we're doing the
open carry in the state capital is that
what you're referring to specifically
show up and they had like some signs and
then there was one that was a plant
where they had like what was it a Nazi
flag and it turned out it is incorrectly
reported or whatever I mean it it it's
all of that the theatrics and and and
the messaging and everything aside the
fact that people were focusing more on
the protesters instead of here you have
elected officials that are doing certain
things that they have no authority in
their state constitutions to do and to
have the the press which is supposed to
be the watchdog of the people not
adequately or accurately reporting on
things for the people they claim to care
about so much that's a little
frightening which is why I'm thankful
for citizen journalism but that that
that was frightening and that's a
problem and I think it just continues to
feed this just trust that people have of
authority ultimately yeah that that's a
good segue also for something that's in
the book that you are always hitting you
know very much in line with what I'm
hitting on let's talk about the press a
little bit sort of mainstream everyone's
watching it collapse everyone's watching
you know the quote-unquote journalists
destroyed journalism does this thing
just need to flame out you know if you
would have asked me maybe six months ago
I was still on oh this thing can be
fixed wagon or at least we should still
be trying to fix it and now after Corona
I'm just like and after what Chuck Todd
did in the last couple weeks with with
Bob Barr and just like watching the rest
of it it's like you know what maybe just
let it crumble and and while I think
there's major risks on the other side if
we have nothing that's mainstream it's
like what gives us national cohesion
it's like why are we saving this thing
or are you in that space or do you think
if there's something worth saving or
some of them so mixed maybe yeah I think
it's kind of a mix I don't ever think
that the press has been unbiased ever
even since its inception I mean I think
of the funny little ways that they used
to like during the days of our founding
that the that folks would go after each
other politicians would write nasty
editorials which were so much more
scandalous than some of the stuff that
we see Wow
I mean that
yeah colonial housewives come to life
that's what it seemed like it was crazy
I don't think that they've ever been
unbiased I do think that they maybe
perhaps have been a little bit more
attentive to the needs of the people
because at one point the price was the
people the press and the people kind of
were hand-in-hand and the press was the
people's way to keep check on their
government and now it's dissolved into
party allegiances and a lot of the press
and there have been surveys the majority
of them identify politically one way as
opposed to the other and I don't even
have a problem with that the problem
that I have is the egos of so many of
these individuals who seem to think that
the byline is the most important thing
on a piece as opposed to the information
that the piece is sharing and or
supposed to share and so many of these q
and A's with the president turned into
some kind of footage for a reporter to
aggrandize themselves and and make a
story out of themselves or it's all prop
it's you know political propaganda and
it's it's frustrating because I always
feel you know a free press is a sacred
thing and I will defend that to the end
but are they free though when they
cannot report on things outside of that
that political filter when everything
has to run that party affiliation is
that really free reporting and I also
think that criticism of the press seems
to be taboo now but a lot of people in
the press don't seem to understand that
a free press and a free people's right
to criticize their Free Press these are
things that go hand in hand you can't
have one without the other and you can't
criticize our criticism of you without
kind of ultimately betraying your
principles so I I wish I don't like I
said I don't mind bias when it's honest
but I don't want people to report
something and have it be politically you
know one-sided and then try to rely on
the credit earned by a previous media
generation back when they at least
attempted to not place so much emphasis
on the byline or who was anchoring the
news at that particular point and and
really just I wish that they would just
focus on the information
and if they want to do editorial do
editorial like I'm not a journalist I
I'm not a heart I'm not a reporter I'm
I'm an editorial listen to an analyst I
am so biased it's crazy but I admit it
and I'll be honest with people about it
but just just just I want them to do the
same as well just be honest about it do
you think people get confused when
people attack the media there seems to
be this idea that if people like you and
I attack the media that somehow we're
part of the problem or the other version
of this is like when when Trump fights
with everyone at CNN he's fighting with
Jim Acosta and people are like he's
attacking the press and it's like well I
actually have no problem with that he
has First Amendment rights to now if he
was using the power of the government
obviously to silence them well now we
got a problem but he as far as I know
he's not doing that yet they love to
play the victim too and it's like what
happens in America constantly is that
everyone is exercising their free speech
all the time I mean we could get to the
big tech problem
maybe in a moment but like that the way
it actually is working
Trump fighting with them them attacking
Trump us attacking them you may not love
the whole game and it may be it may be
something that burns too hot you know so
it's eventually going to explode or
something
well like everyone's free speech is
being you know protected basically no I
think that's a good point I mean isn't
that isn't that what it's all about I
mean America has always been kind of
like a big giant family arguing at the
dinner table and it makes it infuriating
but also amazing I mean I wouldn't
change it for the world and that's what
it's supposed to be like but this idea
that you're you know if you criticize or
the press for bad reporting and there
are numerous examples a bad reporting
there are entire media entities on the
right that exist to document legitimate
cases of biased reporting and that
that's not attacking anyone
they act like they're on a battlefield
and as they're trying to eat their MRE
they're you know being hit with missiles
from the President or from a Republican
or whatever because they dared to write
a bad story I mean they're and that's
that's the point of it we it's a we also
in addition to keeping our politicians
honest we have to keep our press honest
and I feel like we were sold a bit that
was a bad sale like we were supposed to
have them as an employee instead of now
because they have really there are a lot
of people in the press and I know you
would agree with us that have really
abused their position of power and it is
a position of power I will never forget
the story of this elderly lady and I
wrote about it in my book this elderly
woman who had a Facebook group that was
a pro Trump Facebook group I mean you
know she can do whatever she wants you
can play farmville she can do a pro
Trump Facebook group and DNN showed up
at her house on her there her address
was displayed on camera and she ended up
getting threats and I'm thinking wait
because you don't like her political
affiliation you decided to abuse your
authority as a way to really intimidate
people into not engaging in a right that
they have that that's bothersome you
know I've been the victim of press bias
you've been the victim of press bias we
I don't think there's anyone that is in
this industry that hasn't been affected
but the idea that any kind of criticism
of them means that they are being
persecuted I would have to say well you
know there there is a definitive history
as to who reacted what and it wasn't the
people who attacked a by an unbiased
press it was the people who started
pointing out some really unfair and
nasty articles that had been written so
I I don't give a lot of credence - and
when they're unfairly attacked
I'll definitely speak up but not every
one of those attacks are unfair or
criticisms are unfair
so that's actually a perfect segue to
the outrage part of this so as I'm doing
all my press for my book one of the
things that people are asking me
constantly is when did the outrage thing
start is there a moment that you can
point to that it started I have a couple
different answers for it because I think
there's a few things that led up to it
but do you see like a moment or a
political movement or a person that sort
of got us into this mess that now we all
see
oh that's a good question because it
feels like people have been outraged for
so long even since the you know George W
Bush years even maybe even going back to
Reagan people have been outraged for a
long time I remember going the first
time I was ever at the Reagan Library
and I was looking at one of the exhibits
it was about some of the media bias
towards Reagan and those headlines were
nasty and he would say one thing or look
one particular way and there were
headlines about it I think that it's
grown to include almost every aspect of
life so it's it's instead of it just
being a reaction it's now a culture and
when that occurred I I don't know maybe
sometime after George W Bush it's one of
those things where it's been around for
so long we don't realize that we are in
it we haven't we don't realize how long
we've been in it I what do you think it
started so I have a couple different
answers on this but I think you know at
you know my story so as a lefty I was
very much in like the progressive thing
and I think it was sort of the first
time Bernie came around he ignited
although I don't think he himself was
realizing what he was doing exactly he
ignited this like thing that was laying
underneath this like that like there was
tinder basically underneath that he
ignited that sort of everything in
America was bad and that once you do
that you couple that with identity
politics you couple that with you know
twenty years or almost three decades
maybe of kids being told that they can
never lose and their feelings matter and
participation trophies and basically all
of these things that then as we became
more hyper partisan and then you finally
you throw Trump on to it which I think
he was just a symptom of it not the
cause of it but that I think is why the
last five years oh and then of course
you throw social media into it so I
don't know that there's an exact moment
but it was like it was like
hyper-partisan left ninis coupled with
sort of the collapse of the decent
liberal you throw in social media you
throw in trolls you throw in BOTS you
throw in Trump who wants to play that
game you throw in the dishonest media
and we just it was like we it was almost
like we summoned this thing we all sort
of did it together I don't point
- like oh it was April 25th 2007 you
know we summoned a monster it is very
much a Frankenstein's monster kind of
story and you're right social media
intensifies it it's the magnifying glass
through which the sun's rays are leveled
at some of our fellow ants I mean that's
really ultimately what it's like I I
definitely think that the Bernie thing
assured in the whole outrage as a
culture because it's it existed as a
tactic and I remember even seen it
during the Occupy Wall Street days but
definitely with the introduction as not
just a Bernie Sanders but of socialism
as now kind of like a legitimate spring
off of dump the Democrat Party or really
ultimately what the Democrat Party is
now really has taken over and there
isn't a good what happened to the
Liberals where do the liberals go where
did those liberals that you were
Democrats like that even the joe
Manchin's kinda mean he seems like a
decent guy I disagree with him on a
number of policy issues but he seems
like a decent guy right he's not a nasty
person he really focuses on policy but
he's like a dinosaur in the Democrat
Party it's not cool to be time really I
mean it really hasn't it's not I mean
that that's true and and as I said to
you as I said to you on your show the
other day they basically executed order
66 on the Liberals they the progressives
the progressives saw the soft underbelly
of liberalism liberals are nice liberals
are tolerant liberals are decent but
that's the good stuff about liberalism
but what comes with that is this
open-mindedness where we'll let anyone
in and the progressives were like oh
we're gonna do it in the name of
tolerance and decency and diversity but
actually destroy the whole thing they
turned into the biggest Puritans also
ironically so I there are such an odd
there all their belief systems are this
weird dichotomy and I can't
it makes for that and I it's it's very
inconsistent which makes me question the
authenticity it it's the anti racists
who are the racist it's the you know the
the people who say yeah they flip they
flip everything on its head it's it's
sort of bananas what one of the things
that I like that you do
I follow you on Twitter you're on the
short list of people who don't make me
completely insane on Twitter but you get
a lot of hate we all get hate okay we
subject ourselves to it but sometimes
people will say quite horrific things
about you your your family your kids
your husband the whole thing and you'll
just retweet them and say god bless or I
don't agree or like something like that
do you think that ultimately that is the
the key to winning this thing so to
speak if there's a win which is sort of
just be a little better that's kind of
the message that I try to push to
college students is I know it's not easy
because it sucks and nobody wants to be
called these things but just be a little
bit better it's not easy and it's not
rewarded with clicks or likes and it
really goes you won't get it you don't
get anything out of it everybody likes
treating politics like it's a gladdie
it's like a gladiator event and I used
to not always be that way admittedly I
mean I have always kind of been a
brawler even when I was a Democrat I was
always kind of a brawler and I was the
person who would crash protests in
college and I would just even if it was
just myself I would go and crash
protests and do all kinds of stuff but I
also think too at a certain point you
sort of realized well why are we
you ask yourself rather why are why are
you doing what you're doing what you're
doing
why are you are you out here to win just
this argument or are you out here to
like plant a seed into someone's mind
because you really truly want to change
something and I think if the for the
people who really want to and truly want
to change things and do have the best
interests of others at heart they
realize that this is not going to be an
immediate thing no one is going to ever
have their minds changed on Twitter no
one's ever going to have their minds
changed on Facebook or in a five minute
cable news discussion where people are
yelling over each other it's just
entertainment it's it's infotainment
that's all it is the real heavy work
comes from repeated interaction and not
just through the keyboard either and I
used to my well my friend and I used to
work for Andrew Breitbart when before he
passed away he would retweet
all the hateful stuff and he would
engage with a lot of it too but he had
fun doing it and initially I retweeted
it because it did it did make me mad and
I wanted to hurt the other person and I
wanted to make fun of them and I wanted
to just destroy them on a public level
where they would just be nothing but a
smoking pile of ash and then after a
while I'm like what's the point of that
for real what is the point of it because
one more person that I'm able to break
through to and actually have a
conversation with and maybe get them to
agree with me on 80% of the stuff that's
like one less person that I have to
fight or that is gonna make bad policy
you know when my kids get older and
they're gonna have to deal with it and
then I started thinking I don't want my
kids to have to deal with a
Frankenstein's monster that I
participated in creating so what can I
do to make that different and it just
was it wasn't one certain thing that
changed my thinking on on dealing with
the hate aspect of it it was a bunch of
stuff and then when I you know when I
tell people god bless it may look like
I'm being smart outlook but I'm really
not I mean I'm really not wishing
ill-will towards any of them because who
knows I mean maybe some of them would
have been me like 15 years ago and they
just haven't had that moment where they
figured out how to really get in there
and really truly engage and advocate for
what they believe in and I think that
that's a journey that every single
person is on and people come to
different realizations about it at
different times yeah so you've probably
loved the fact that I haven't really
brought up guns with the gun lady but
let's let's do a little bit let's do a
little bit on guns I'm sure I'm not the
first person to refer you as the gun
lady right that's got lady it seems like
they probably have different adjectives
before gun lady there's probably some
other adjectives they put in there lady
also is interchangeable
Touche Touche okay so we actually don't
have to do a ton on it because you do so
much time you spend so much time talking
about this stuff but could you could we
do like two or three things that you
would love to explain to say anti-gun
people or two or three things that are
like the memes that are just
misunderstood about our laws or about
the Second Amendment just a couple
things that we could maybe clean up
because I think you've had to spend a
lot of time doing that sort of thing
there was that infamous CNN Town Hall
after Parkland and and that was just an
absolute fiasco but maybe just a couple
of the things that people should know
that maybe they don't fully grasp or
something like that ya know I I think
the the biggest thing is a lot of people
think that their anti-gun but they're
not they're really not they are anti you
having a gun because they don't trust
themselves and because they don't trust
themselves and they don't have
confidence and their ability to handle
it they project that onto other
individuals I always tell people if
you're anti-gun then you really don't
believe and you I mean you shouldn't
believe in calling the police to come
with their guns if you have a need where
firepower is required as a solution
you shouldn't hire private security if
you're anti-gun and I think that the
idea of well I'm okay with guns so long
as you know private security has them or
police have them and there was a guy who
actually suppose a couple of weeks ago
who on Twitter was telling me oh yeah I
work for the firm that you know moms
demand hires whenever they have events
and I've had moms demand and Everytown
confirm this to me separately from this
but you're hiring private security for
you but you don't want other individuals
to have that access I don't want to
outsource the carrying of my firearm and
that seems really classist if we're to
have a discussion about legitimate class
warfare I would think the idea that only
people wealthy enough to hire private
security to protect them that is
incredibly classist because not
everybody has Bloomberg money not
everybody is in that position and so if
you're truly anti-gun then you would
believe that for police and military and
everything else it's it's not a little
bit of a position it's it
that's one of the the areas that I think
is either/or and there are very few
areas where there really isn't a lot of
nuance I think that an abridgment of a
natural right is a denial of a right so
that would be like that would be the
first thing and the second thing is that
we've always had firearms and we have
more laws now than we ever had and we
have seen only in terms of youths acting
out in ways where they shouldn't and
accessing firearms I think that we are
ignoring a really serious problem in our
society with younger people with young
males particularly and I know you've
talked about this before on your program
a lot of people have discussed this tour
and Peterson has talked about this this
is not getting enough attention and I'm
a boy mom and I can see how easy it is
for young men to go off the rails and
young women can - but there's something
different with young men and it's really
easy for them to go off the rails and
it's almost we are in a society that is
- in my opinion is hostile towards young
men and all young men and then it gets
into varying degrees of severity
depending on different boxes checked and
there all of that is is just making a
kindling for this problem and until we
deal with that we're always going to
have these problems but you're not going
to solve it by punishing law-abiding
people who are not the fuel for this
problem and then I guess the last thing
all of the laws that people keep saying
that we need we we have I mean every
single thing that was the one I really
wanted you to hit yeah every single day
I see somebody propose something and
they're like oh well we should know
crazy people that can buy guns oh okay
well you can have someone committed or
you can you know request there's a whole
way to go about this that preserves due
process and protects innocent people the
red flag law terrifies me and because
it's a removal of due process red flag
laws aren't even about guns red flag
laws are complete removal of due process
guns are a variable in this situation
and when people realize that that a
firearm is a variable and we
you set this precedent of completely
obliterating someone's ability to have
that protection of due process you are
going to be able to accuse people and
convict them before a trial on any
number of things this isn't just about
guns think of an it think of an issue
and that to me is a terrifying beginning
to full Yvette's
that's a terrifying concept and the fact
that some are so incredibly
lackadaisical about it they're willing
to under to remove that that pin of of
our republic just to what because they
think they're gonna cancel out Second
Amendment that's that's a horrible way
to do it do you think that the the real
tough part is well you gotta explain
some truth okay so that that's tough but
the left generally is much better at the
bumper sticker answers and that is
usually what people who aren't really
thinking want to swallow I mean the
easiest version of this is when I go to
my local supermarket there is a sign on
the outside and has a gun and it's
crossed out and says this is a gun-free
zone and if you're an average left-knee
I think you walk in there and you're
like you feel good you're like oh well
there'll be no guns in here that's
fantastic and of course all you have to
do like most things unfortunately that
come out of the left these days think
about it for about 6 to 8 seconds and
usually what you'll find is oh you know
the bad guys they probably don't pay
attention to the stickers but but to do
what you just did there is takes a lot
more time takes more attention takes
more work and knowledge rather than
here's a sticker on the door I feel good
about it to you yeah well and the
stickers don't create this like
invisible force field like that's that
Star Trek technology does not yet exist
in our or maybe it does and we just
don't know maybe that's what those UFO
videos are about but we should prevent
bad guys from coming into the area you
know they're not gonna show up illegally
in possession of a firearm and I hate
the phrase illegal guns it's always
illegal possession they're not gonna
show up with an illegally possessed
gonna go you know what I was gonna go in
here and do some really shady stuff but
this sticker it's thicker thicker it
that doesn't it yeah that does that's
never happened and John Lott who
is a walking encyclopedia he's done a
lot of research on this and I think what
is it like the vast majority of mass
casualty incidents these mass shootings
that have taken place from the period of
1953 till the current time have been in
gun-free zones and a lot of these
gun-free zones they don't even have
right they don't even have armed
security to protect that or at least try
to protect the people that they allow to
come in so that that is like Linus's
blanket right it's a safety blanket this
idea of a gun free anything and why
don't you just put a sign out that says
crime free where does some crime
acceptable to you just a crime-free zone
sticker that this is it's never work we
we live in a reality where this is what
I think freedom scares some freedom
scares people some people
cannot handle freedom because they don't
i think trust themselves and they don't
trust other people and there are going
to be people that are going to abuse
their freedom and even after they have
been caught and they have faced justice
and they have been punished they're
still going to reoffended they're still
going to choose to do bad things with
their free will
and the you will you're never going to
be able to legislate evil away because
you cannot legislate that away in each
individual and the the solution isn't to
remove people's ability to defend
themselves the solution is to make
criminals afraid with more severe
penalties instead of I mean I could sit
here and talk to you about our justice
system on and on and on because I think
we have a massive problem and we have
too many felonies and you know some of
the nonviolent it just you know goes on
and on but for the serious offenders
there need to be penalties that really
are adequate deterrence and and allow a
quit punishing the law-abiding for what
these people choose to freely do and I
always tell people you know they're no
such thing as loopholes it's like if
someone is caught driving under the
influence they have their license
suspended and they continue going in it
in and driving a vehicle they get caught
that's not a loophole they're breaking
the law that's a criminal act
so these loopholes that people keep
talking about there's criminal acts and
non criminal acts there's no nuance
there the ATF has things covered to the
point of being over covered so there's
there's a criminal act and then there's
a non criminal act
there's no loophole but we always hear
about the gun show loophole I know the
gun show loophole because you know you
always have gang members day of going
out there and buying super expensive
collectors guns and then going out and
committing all of these crimes with
collectors items and even that is even
even private sales are regulated to a
point and the penalty on that is
incredibly high but that's not how I
mean gangbangers they've done surveys on
this they're people who are committing
crimes are getting this off the black
market and if you think you're gonna
eradicate the black market I mean look
how well the war on drugs has gone you
think that this is gonna be any
different I mean it's the same thing
different variable
are you hopeful for America at this
point like we can talk about all the the
scary stuff and the frustrations and
young people have problems and the media
is collapsing and it feels like our
institutions are crumbling and kovat and
we don't have a trusted sources like all
of this stuff but I sense that
underneath that is is some hope or some
glance I like to market myself as a
perpetual cynic and I think it just
comes by way of being like you know
young Gen X I just am a cynic and that's
like the Gen X thing is to be cynical
but I have a supreme appreciation and
fondness for that crazy American spirit
the spirit that drove people to go hey
let's just take a wagon and go way out
in the wilderness we have no idea what's
gonna happen but we're just going to
just create something out there it is an
animating spirit that of Liberty and it
gives it makes people courageous and it
has made this country in such a short
period of time this beacon on the hill
this this amazing thing and I I'm
hopeful because of that and I even think
you know even with some of the
progressives out there you'll notice
they're you know they're critical of you
know even though they're leftist and
some of them are socialists and some of
them are say that they're communists
they're all pretty critical of Communist
China they're pretty critical of G
Jinping so there is still something in
that American DNA that is is making them
rebel against at least a somewhat
against authoritarianism the news you
know the news looks bad I just know that
media likes selling you bad news so I
don't really pay any attention to that
but I'm hopeful because of the stuff
that I see in little bits that doesn't
get reported you know the story of you
know the guy who goes around and cuts
you know the elderly people's yards
because they don't have the means or
ability to do it themselves and I see
little bitty things or you know even
like the kids in California when the
city dumped sand in their skate park and
they went out and they cleaned the sand
out of the skate park it was one of the
most awesome things I've ever seen I'm
like that you know that kind of stuff
that stuff that's what brings me home
and and the smart alec knows of those
kids that's what brings me hope I love
that the idea you know the two women who
got busted in Laredo and they ended up
also getting free by Texas Supreme Court
order they were cosmetologist doing
services in their homes they're doing
speakeasies I mean that's like a
prohibition-era kind of thing I love it
they were creative and they were going
around the man that's an awesome thing
so I and the fact that Greg Abbott now
says we can have home delivery of liquor
kits that's amazing I think I've sent
his office like a couple of emails st.
that's go away you know there's a little
I think you say I they're gonna say a
couple of cases of whiskey just a couple
emails oh man no you can go and get what
is it one's a bourbon bloom kit and then
you can actually get like frozen
margaritas now which and he's like yeah
we may not ever have these regulations
come back in god bless Texas so I you
know there's little goofy things that I
can point to but ultimately you know I
am hopeful it's it's it's hard to be a
cynic when you see that kind of stuff
and I am hopeful and I know that there's
enough rabble-rousers out there and
smartasses out there who really just
they give me hope you know I don't know
how I don't know how much to put it but
they do
all right well everyone can follow you
on twitter at dana lotion in the words
of dana loesch god bless
there you go god bless if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell